ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
โว่เช้าเอา 5 กลับมาเจอการกำลังเจอเปีย
ตี้กับมาเจอห้องเรียมใน Also เรียมในช่อง
คอม friend สิเบิ้ลไทยนะครับ
ครับวันนี้เรามาเจอกันเรามาเจอกันวันนี้
เจอกันวันอะไรครับ
ว่าวันนี้วันอะไรวันนี้วันศุกร์
ปากกาที่พี่เปิดกามาเดี๋ยวนี้
งงแค่วันศุกร์มีครับวันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่
ครับวันนี้วันศุกร์ที่
28  5 วันนี้วันศุกร์ที่
28 ว้าววันศุกร์ที่ 28 แล้วแล้วเดือนนี้
ครับเดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือนอะไรครับเดือน
คนเดือนมกราคม 5 เดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมใน
ครับเดือนมกราคมแล้วปีข้อศ.อะไรครับ
คอ
ตต้าพันธุ์ 22  5
2540  2 นะครับปีนี้นะครับแล้วปีพตอะไร
ครับ
พ.ต.ต.
2560  555
2565 เคเคได้ครับปีพ.ศ
เมื่อกี้เดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมใช่ไหมหาแล้ว
เดือนหน้าเดือนหน้าเดือนเท่าไหร่ครับ
เดือนหน้าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์นะครับ 5 แล้วเดือนนี้ You
can
ก่อนดีคือก่อน
เดือนก่อนอันนี้เดือนนี้
เดือนก่อนเดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนก่อนเดือนธันวาคมชายครับเดือนก่อน
เดือนธันวาคมน่ะคนไทยเรียกเดือนก่อนหรือ
เดือนที่แล้วที่แล้วกินแล้วไส้เหมือนกัน
เหมือนกันเดือนก่อนเดือนธันวาคมเดือนที่
แล้วเดือน
ธันวาคมหน้าเหมือนกันโอเคโอเคอ่าแล้ววัน
นี้ครับวันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันกี่โมง
ครับกี่โมงครับตอนนี้ตอนนี้
11:00 นนหา
11:00 นครึ่งนะครับครึ่ง
อ่าครึ่งคือ 30 นะครับครึ่งหนึ่งห้า 11:30
นนะครับโอเคอะบางทีบางทีคนไทยเรียกเรี่ยน
5:00 น 5:00 น 6:30 นฮ่าๆๆ 17:30 นนัก
เรียนอย่างจำได้ไหมจำได้ไหมคนไทยเรียก
ด้านนี้หน้าคนไทยเรียก 1  2  3  4  4  5
5 ตอนนี้
05:30 น 05:30 เป็นตอนเช้าหรือตอนเย็น
ครับ
ตอนเช้าค่ะอ้าตอนเช้าใช่ไหมอ่ะ 5 โมง
ครึ่งหน้ามีพระอาทิตย์ช้ายาตอนนี้เป็นพระ
อาทิตย์ขึ้นนะครับ 17:30 น
แค่ตอนนี้ 5:30 นแล้วอ่าอีก
อีกกี่ชั่วขอ
อีกกี่ชั่วโมงดีอีก 3 ชั่วโมงอีก 3
ชั่วโมงกี่โมงครับ 3 ชั่วโมงเวลาชั่วโมง
เวลา
14:00 นวันนี้นะตอนนี้ 1 ใจไหม
ตอนนี้อยู่ตรงนี้อันนี้เป็นหนึ่งอย่างตัว
นี้เป็น 2 เท่านี้เป็น 3
ใช่ไหมพี่อาร์ตี้นับถูกเลยล่ะถูกเชื่อ
โอเคก็เป็นอีก 2 ชั่วโมง
พี่ถามสองหรือสาว
สาวเปียพี่ถามป่าเตรียมได้ยิน 3 อ๋อโอเค
อีก 3 ชั่วโมงก็ต้องเป็น
บ่ายโมงหรอ
13:15 นเหรอหรือบายออกไปนี้ 1  2  3
แต่บ่าย 2 โมงสิ
บ่าย 14:30 นน่าใช้ครับบ่าย 14:30 นโอเค
อ่าตอนนี้วันที่เท่านี้เราเรียนอะไรกันนะ
ครับมาเรียนอะไรทัน
อ๋อวันนี้เตรียมจะให้พี่อาร์ตี้ช่วยเลือก
เลือกเท้าเรื่องรองเท้าหรอโอเคเรือกรอง
เท้านะมีรองเท้าอะไรให้พี่อาร์ตี้เลือก
บ้างครับเปียที่วาดรูปรองเท้ากันฮ่าๆ
เหมือนไหมรองเท้าโอเคๆมีรอยสาว
โอ๊ะนี่อะไรครับ
อันนี้คือขาวขาวๆอ๋อเป็นเท้านะครับ
ขาวขับ
ตรงนี้เป็นนิ้วเท้า
ก็จะมีนิ้วเท้า
ห้านิ้วเท้านิ้วทางนั้นตรงนั้นนิ้วใหญ่
ที่สุด
นิ้วใหญ่ที่สุดใหญ่ที่สุดอายุใหญ่ที่สุด
เรียกเพียงนิ้วอะไรเขา
นิ้วโป้งอาเรียนนิ้วโป้งอ่าเดี๋ยวนี้นิ้ว
โป้งใช่ไหมใหญ่ที่สุดใหญ่ที่
ใจแอบนิ้วโป้งโอเคอ่านิ้วโป้งเท้าใช่ไหม
ใช่เท้าอ้าโอเคไปครับต่อไป
มีเท้าแล้วก็
มีส้นเท้า
มีส้นเท้าส้นเท้าอยู่ตรงไหนครับอ้าอยู่
ตรงนั้นน่ะส้นเท้า
ครับแล้วก็มีตาตุ่มตาตุ่มโอตาตุมอยู่ตรง
ไหนครับขออยู่ตรงนั้นตาตุ่มแต่ตาตู่นี้
เป็นตาตาไม่ใช่ปลานี้เลยไม่ใช่นะเป็นไม่
คาสุ่มห้าตุ่มดิบต้มโอเคธาตุก
แล้วก็มี
ข้อเท้าฮอเท้าอ่ออ่อตรงนั้นอ่ะเป็นข้อ
เท้าอ่ะเหมือนกับเหมือนกับพี่เคยได้ยิน
เคยได้ยินคอกข้อมือ
ข้อมือล้อมีข้อมือแล้วก็มีข้อเท้าด้วยนะ
มีข้อเท้า
ใช่ค่ะขับอันนี้คือหลังเท้าหลังเท้าตรง
ไหนครับขอตรงนี้เป็นหลังเท้าอ้าเหมือนกัน
เหมือนกันมือมือก็มีหลังหลังมือเป็นหลัง
มือโอเคมีหลังมือมือมีหลังเท้าครับแล้วก็
มีฝากขาวป่าหน้าหนาวอ๋อโอเคฝาเท้ามีฝ่า
เท้าแล้วก็มีฝ่ามือด้วยเหมือนกันใช่ไหม
ป่า
หลังมือเข้
ใช่ค่ะแต่วันนี้ไอ้ไม่ช่วยเลือกลิ้นเท้า
อาเลือกรองเท้านี่ใช่รองเท้าอะไรให้พี่
อาร์ตี้เลือกบ้างครับ
เนื้อ
เรียมถามพี่อาร์ตี้ครับถ้าเรียมจะไปกิน
ข้าวไปกินข้าวหากินข้าวที่ที่ทะเลใช่มั้ย
พี่ริมทะเล
อันนี้คือน้ำทะเลอ้าวโอ้มีน้ำทะเลด้วยอ่ะ
น้องเรียนไปกินข้าวที่ทะเลโอเค
นะตรงนี้คือหาดทราย
ครับมีโอ๊ยตาย
ใช่เรียม
เลือกใส่รองเท้า
ไหนคะอ๋ออ๋อรองเท้าคู่ไหนดีใช่ไหมครับอ่ะ
เฮียตีช่วยเลือกให้ว่าน้องเรียนจะใส่คู่
ไหนดีมีรองเท้าอะไรบ้างครับมีรองเท้าอะไร
ให้เลือกบ้างครับมีรองเท้า
เบอร์ 1 เบอร์ 1 อยู่ตรงไหนครับลองเท้า
อ้าสีสีแดงเบอร์อะไรครับอ๋อเห็นแล้วเห็น
แล้วที่เห็นนะถ้าเห็นเลขโอเคน้องเอ็ม
เขียนเลขข้างบนได้ไหมเขียนข้างบนรองเท้า
ได้ห่าอ้าโอเคเห็นแล้วเห็นแล้วอ่านี่เห็น
แล้วนักเรียนเลื่อนขึ้นมาเลื่อนขื้นมา
เกียติเฮ
ๆๆหรือยัง 1 เบอร์ 2 หรือเบอร์ 3 ใช่ไหม
พี่ติ๊กคิดๆค่ะคิดว่าน้องเรียม R ใส่
เบอร์ 1 เบอร์หนึ่งน่าจะดีน่าจะดี
ใช้ครับนาเบอร์ 1 เป็น
รองเท้าที่รัดข้อเท้า 5 ทรายครับรัดข้อ
เท้านะครับ
นี่มาสเดอนนตายได้เดินบนทรายได้ใช้ขับ
สบายๆชาย
แล้วเปิดสองก็รัดข้อเท้า
เหมือนกันได้ครับรัดข้อเท้าเหมือนกันมี
เชือกมีเชือกผูกข้อเท้าหรือใช่ค่ะเชื่อ
ก.ย
[เพลง]
และเตรียมคิดว่าเตรียมเลือกเบอร์ 1 ล้อ
ใช้หาพักเพียงตีคิดว่าเบอร์ 1 ใส่ง่าย
กว่าใส่ง่ายใส่ง่ายคอร์ดง่าย
น้าได้
สบายๆๆขับ
ใช่แล้วเบอร์ 3 เบอร์ 3 รองเท้าสีแดงกับ
รองเท้าสีแดงเป็นรองเท้าหุ้มส้นใช่ครับ
รองเท้าหุ้มส้นถ้านักเรียนใส่รองเท้าหุ้ม
ส้นเดินบนพื้นทรายทรายเข้าไปเข้าไปไหนรอง
เท้าใต้งับไม่ดีไม่ดี
ก็ไม่ดีค่ะ
ตายก็จะเข้ามาใช่เข้าไปไหนรองเท้า
[เพลง]
ต่อไปมาแล้วถ้า
ถ้าเรียงไปที่ไปไหนครับ
ห้างสรรพสินค้าข้าวไปห้างสรรพสินค้าอ้า
น้องเรียนไปทำอะไรที่ห้างสรรพสินค้าครับ
เตรียมก็ไปซื้อขอไปซื้อของ
ไม่เจอเกินเดินแล้วโอเคของ
หน้าใส่รองเท้าคู่ไหนดีใช่ไหมครับค่ะ 1
คู่ที่ 2 หรือคู่ที่ 3 ดี 5 พชร์ตี้คิด
ว่าคิดว่าถ้าไปเดินน้องเรียนไปเดินซื้อ
ของหาเดินซื้อของเยอะๆใส่รองเท้าคู่ที่ 2
คู่ที่ 2 ดีครับ
ใครครับที่ 2 ใช้อ่ะติดต่อเนื้อคู่ที่ 2
ตรงกลางตรงกลางป่าผู้ที่สองเรียกว่ารอง
เท้าอะไรคะอ้าเรียกรองเท้าผ้าใบ
รองเท้าผ้าใบอ่ะ
คิดว่าคิดว่านักเรียนนักเรียนรู้จักรอง
เท้าคู่ที่ 2
แน่ๆๆๆ
[เพลง]
แล้วเรียมเห็นมีคนใส่รองเท้าคู่ที่ 1
เกินฮ่าๆๆไปเดินห้างอ่าได้ครับใส่รองเท้า
คู่ที่ 1 ไปเดินได้แต่ว่าท่านเดินนานๆ
เดินนานๆไม่สบายไม่สบายใช่ครับเจ็บตาขอ
ให้หาคู่ที่ 2 เดินนานๆดีกว่าดีกว่าหรือ
เดินเดินๆไปดีไปหาคู่ที่ 2 ถ่ายครับแล้ว
คู่ที่ 1 เรียกว่าอะไรคะอ่ะคู่ที่ 1
เรียกว่ารองเท้าแตะครับรองเท้าแตะ
รองเท้าแตะใช่ครับอ๋อ
แล้วคู่ที่ 3 ล่ะคะอ๋ออ๋อว่าใครหน้าคู่
ที่ 3 เป็นรองเท้ากีฬาครับกีฬาฟุตบอลนะ
ครับเรียกว่ารองเท้าสตั๊ด
เท้าสตั๊ดใส่แล้วก็วิ่งวิ่งเตะฟุตบอลเตะ
ศกรทรายใช้ขับ
เตะบอลนี่หน่าๆเตะฟุตบอล
เนื้อเงินรองเท้าสตั๊ดถ้า
เทียบที่ใส่รองเท้าสตั๊ดไปเดินห้างไหมคะ
หาใส่รองเท้าสตั๊ดเดินห้างไม่ได้ครับ
เพราะว่ารองเท้าสตั๊ดจะมีจะมีปุ่มแน่นัก
เรียนมชี้ตรงปุ่มที่รองเท้าไส้ปุ่มที่รอง
เท้าเอาไว้วิ่งบนสนามหญ้าวิ่งบนสนามหญ้า
ถ้ามันเดินๆถ้าเราใส่รองเท้าสตั๊ดมาเดิน
ในห้างก็จะมีเสียงทึบ
ๆแล้วก็ลื่นด้วยลื่นลื่นๆครับเลื่อย 5
โม้
เรียมเห็นมีรองเท้าสีเหลืองทั้งหมดเลยอ่า
รองเท้าสีเหลืองทั้ง 3 คู่เลยใช่ครับ
ใช่ค่ะเบอร์หนึ่งก็เป็นรองเท้าแตะชายรอง
เท้าแตะหลังขอ
เบอร์ 2 ก็เป็นรองเท้าผ้าใบได้ค่ะพี่
เหลือง
เบอร์ 3 ก็เป็นรองเท้าสตั๊ดหน้าใช่ครับสี
เหลืองเหมือนกันหรือใช่ค่ะห้างก็ห้างสี
เหลืองอ่ะ
เค
ให้เครียดที่เลือกเบอร์ไหนนะคะเพื่อที่
เลือกเบอร์ 2 ครับเบอร์ 2 เบอร์ 2 ว้าว
โอเค
เราจะใส่รองเท้าเบอร์ 2 แหวนห้าง 5 โอเค
ไปครับไปเดินห้างแล้วมีไปที่ไหนอีกครับไป
ที่ไหนนะ
หน้ามีที่ไหน
นิที่ใช้ห่านไปมาแล้วห้างไปมาแล้วนะครับ
เธอมีที่ไหนอีกไหม
โอ้ว้าวไปเต้นบัลเล่ต์เต้นบัลเล่ต์นะครับ
มาท่าเต้นบัลเล่ต์ทุกใส่รองเท้าอะไรกับ
นักเรียนงานนักเรียนช่วยช่วยน้องเรียมดู
หน่อยครับว่าจะใส่รองเท้าคู่ไหนครับไป
เต้นบัลเล่ต์ใช่ไหมอ่า 5 มีเบอร์นึง
Birds  2 แล้วก็เบอร์ 3  5 เพื่อดีคิด
ว่านี้ง่ายมากเลยนักเรียนต้องรู้แน่ๆเลย
ว่ารองเท้าที่ใส่เต้นบัลเล่ต์ลองเท้า
เบอร์อะไร
เบอร์อะไรครับพี่ตี้รู้แล้วพี่ตีเห็นรอง
เท้าที่พี่ก็รู้แล้วหือเบอร์อะไรคะพี่
อาร์ตี้อาร์ตี้อาร์ตี้รู้ว่าไม่ใช่เบอร์ 2
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เบอร์ 3 ไม่ใช่ก็ต้องเป็น
เบอร์ 1  5 เบอร์หนึ่งๆครับ
เรียกว่ารองเท้าอะไรคะอ้าเรียกว่ารองเท้า
บัลเล่ต์ใช่ไหมครับน้าลองถ่ายไปให้
เท้าบัลเล่ต์แล้วเบอร์สองหรอคะเบอร์สอบ
อะไรอ่ะลองเบอร์ 2 เป็นรองเท้าสำหรับเล่น
ไอซ์สเก็ตหน้ารองเท้าไอซ์สเก็ตทรายขับ
หรือว่าจะเรียกสั้นๆว่ารองเท้าสเก็ตห่าอา
รองเท้าสเก็ตได้ครับๆเขารองเท้าสเก็ตแต่
บางครั้งเราจะนี้รู้ว่าเป็นอะรองเท้า
สเก็ตอะไร 5 บางทีก็จะมีรองเท้าสเก็ตหน้า
แบบเบอร์ 3 เบอร์ 3 เราก็เรียกรองเท้า
สเก็ตเหมือนกันช่างแต่ว่าไม่ขอเบอร์ 3
ไม่ได้เล่นสเก็ตบนน้ำแข็ง
ส่วน 2 เล่นสเก็ตบนน้ำแข็งเราเลยเรียกรอง
เท้า ice  skate หน้าเพราะเล่นบนน้ำแข็ง
ใส่ถังค่ะเบอร์ 3 จะเรียกรองเท้า
โรลเลอร์สเก็ตชายโรลเลอร์สเก็ตเพราะว่า
เพราะว่ามีล้อมีรอมีล้อโลเลอร์ใช้ครับก็
เลยเรียกรองเท้าญเลิกสเก็ตใส่กับ
เฮียติดตอบถูกไหมครับเบอร์หนึ่งนักเรียน
เลือกเบอร์ 1 อ่ะไปถูกต้องค่ะ
เต้นบัลเล่ต์ใช่ไหมอ่ะใส่รองเท้าบัลเล่ต์
เต้นเล่ห์
โรงเรียนมเต้นบัลเล่ต์ด้วยใช่ไหมเอา
บัลเล่ต์แห้ง
อ้าวๆก็
ไม่ได้เต้นบัลเล่ต์เอาโอเค
หน้าวันนี้วันนี้เราเรียนเรื่องรองเท้า
กันมีรองเท้าอะไรบ้างนะครับ
มี
มีรองเท้า
รองเท้ารัดข้อเท้ารัดข้อไซส์ไหมอ่าเดิน
ชายหาดได้หน้าเราก็มีรองเท้าต้องใช้นิ้ว
ส้นหุ้มซ่อนนะเค
ครับมีอะไรอีกมีอีก
รองเท้าแตะรองเท้าแตะอ่ะโอเครองเท้าแตะก็
ใส่ไปชายหาดได้นะรองเท้าแตะใช่ไหมครับอ่า
หน้าซ้ายกับมีรองเท้าแต่รองเท้าผ้าใบใช่
ไหม by  k  k แล้วก็มีรองเท้า
สตั๊ดหน้ารองเท้าสตั๊ดใส่เตะฟุตบอลโอเค
ครับฟุตบอล
และก็มีรองเท้าอะไรอีกครับรองเท้า
บัลเล่ต์วอลเลย์โอเค
หลังช่อฟ้าไว้ S  Ice  Age  ka แล้วก็สุด
ท้ายครับสุดท้ายเป็นรองเท้าโรลเลอร์สเก็ต
ใช่ค่ะโอเค
เราก็เลือกเลือกใส่รองเท้ารองเท้าให้ถูก
ต้องแล้ว
ใช่ค่ะ KR วันนี้เราได้เรียนรู้เรื่องรอง
เท้ากันนะครับไปแล้วนะครับก็ถ้านักเรียน
มีข้อสงสัยและสงสัยว่ารองเท้าอันไหนเรียก
อะไรอ่ะนักเรียนถามถามเพียงตีถามนักเรียน
ได้ในคอมเม้นน่ะขี้มาในคอมเม้นต์นะครับ
ใช่แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเราจะเรียนเรื่อง
อะไรนะครับคอยติดตามกันคราวหน้านะครับวัน
นี้พี่อาร์ตี้กับน้องเรียมนะครับต้องลาไป
ก่อนแล้วพี่ก่อน 5 ฮะโอเคสวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนน่ะสวัสดีครับเพียวมีเมียม by  buy
a